[Music]  English lessons today's any English  lesson is on to confusing and adverse I  have a question  did you work hard or do you hardly work  I work hard  let me tell you something some of my  colleagues hardly work in fact I hardly  ever see them in fact what's the  difference between to work hard and to  hardly work well heart and heart are  both art and force with effort hardly  work hard play hard  think hard breathe hard this is an  adverb of manner it goes at the end of  the sentence  hardly this is an adverb of degree this  goes in the middle position  I hardly work I hardly know him it's  hardly raining let's recap what's the  difference between I work hard and I  hardly work think hard  and you get the answer